Hmm.
The first started working on this book I
wrote to do lists the same way that most
people write to do lists and it turns
out this is exactly the wrong way to
write it to do list according to
psychologist and neurologist.
I would sit down in the morning and I
would just jot down all the tasks I
wanted to do that day and I would put on
a couple of things at the top of my page
that were like pretty easy to do cause
it cause I,
it felt so good to cross those off like
early in the day and feel a sense of
accomplishment and I'd put my big tasks
at the bottom of the page.
Sometimes at the top of the page I would
even write things that I had already
done because it just made me so happy to
like sit at my desk and be able to cross
something off right away.
Psychologists call this using a to do
list for mood repair rather than for
productivity.
And it turns out this is exactly the
wrong way to write a,
to do list the right way to write a,
to do list.
The way that genuinely productive people
and companies write to do lists is it
that at the top of the page,
they write their big ambition,
their stretch goal.
They write something that seems almost
impossible to achieve because that
reminds you all day long what you
actually want to get done.
And then underneath they write out a
plan,
they write a smart goal,
they break that big ambition into small
components.
Now that gives me a way to start in the
morning,
but what's important is that when I get
something accomplished,
when I'm able to cross something off my
to do list,
I don't experience that sense of relief
that allows me to,
uh,
go spend half an hour or 90 minutes like
on facebook,
right?
I don't feel like I,
I can take a break and I can go waste
time wandering around.
I'm ready to start on the next task
because of the top of my page.
I'm constantly being reminded that
although I'm making incremental
progress,
this is in service to a bigger goal.
There's something bigger and more
meaningful that I want to accomplish
this day.
And as long as I'm being reminded of
that,
but I still have a plan study after
study shows,
I'm much more likely to get more things
done and to focus on the right things
each day.
Mm.